la muerte de otro joven palestino de
nombre sala alburete en un operativo más
de arresto israelí en jerin es solo la
punta de unas semanas de violencia que
van en grave aumento en cisjordania y
Jerusalén este desde marzo y tras una
serie de ataques de atentados en Israel
el ejército israelí ha convertido en
Norma a estas redadas que califica de
contra terrorismo pero no solo están
alimentando más violencia sino que han
causado la muerte de 124 palestinos
muchos milicianos pero también civiles y
menores además junto a estas redadas las
fuerzas y relieves han apelado a
bloqueos de urbes y zonas que ellos
consideran focos de violencia de ahí el
cierre de nabús que justo hoy alcanza el
décimo día con una interrupción de
clases presenciales mercados y atención
médica la respuesta Palestina a toda
esta violencia está presentándose en dos
formas una muy extendida son las
protestas y huelgas en escuelas y
comercios como la que se vivió este
jueves ayer otra es el surgimiento de
nuevas Mili formadas formadas por
jóvenes que No necesariamente están
ligados a una facción la más prominente
es la lions La Guarida de los leones que
surgió Precisamente en navús en medio de
todo esto también se han intensificado
los ataques de Colón los judíos que
según el diario israelí harets han
realizado más de 100 agresiones en los
últimos 10 días entre ellas muchas
ligadas a la recogida de aceitunas como
un ataque a una voluntaria israelí de 70
años pero también a una unidad de las
fuerzas israelíes en cisjordania para
las facciones palestinas en gaza todo
esto es como una etapa de Nueva etapa de
liberación de cisjordania pero lo cierto
Es que este es Ya el año más violento
desde 2015